hello everyone and welcome to a truly
amazing game and definitely an inspiring
one a subscriber sent me uh saying he
sacrificed his Queen three times and
like I said in the previous video I
often get a game surprise subscribers
played and uh sometimes they're nice
sometimes they're not that nice but uh
this one I felt that it was necessary to
to show everyone as it's really a a
beautiful beautiful game uh it's between
a player on chess.com uh with a with a
handle even rated 1697 and a player
named uh Bill Habib Mahi uh rated 1704
so let's dive straight into it you guys
will enjoy it and some of you have been
asking in the previous videos is it
necessary to wear a hoodie uh when we're
watching a game between two hoodie guys
like it's not necessary but if you're
already wearing one I imagine you will
enjoy the game much more so let's dive
straight into it uh even uh has the
white pieces and he opens with E4 or
maybe it's Ivan uh who who knows uh we
have C5 going for the Sicilian Defense
by Bel Habib Mahi uh Knight to F3 E6 and
now Pawn to D4 C characters and D4
Knight captures and now usually you
would see some like Knight F6 and then
we go into the night or four something
like that but here the immediate Ponte
A6 this is the Khan variation of the
Sicilian Knight to C3 and now Queen to
C7 we have Bishop to E2 and now Knight
to C6 and white just captures on C6 so
Knight captures on C6 and there are many
games that reach this position it's uh
not uh unusual to have this like uh
Girish Academy against the animation
their game ended in a draw B captures
and C6 was played also while it has a
future head against Mastro vasilis also
be captures and C6 was played and it's a
principled idea to capture towards the
center however here we have D captures
on C6 which is not all that common there
are some games that reach this position
uh for example Castle is a normal A4 is
a known but here we have Pawn to G3 and
it is now as of move 8 that we we have a
completely new game between these uh two
gentlemen
and now we have Knight to F6 uh
developing the Knight sort of inviting
E5 but not right away as the queen on C7
covers that square but also uh G3 being
played you might have to worry about
Bishop to F4 at some point not right
away you can always block it with E5 so
it remains to see where the bishop will
be developed and that is uh to the G5
Square so Bishop G5 Bishop to E7 not
worrying about now Bishop captures
because Bishop can recapture on F6 we
have Castles by white and now Ponte H6
Bishop back to F4 inviting black to play
E5 which black does spawn the E5 Bishop
to E3 and now a nice developing move
with the bishop Bishop to H3 comes with
tempo as The Rook on F1 is hanging we
have Rook to E1 and now again developing
which Tempo Rook the d8 so a very very
principled play by black attacking the
queen on D1 Queen to C1 now and now Pawn
to H5 you could Castle right away but uh
Bill Habib Mahi wanted to gain more than
than just a nice game so upon the H5 he
wants to play Pawn to H4 open up the H
file for his Rook uh and here okay you
have to be very very careful but if you
play something like F3 then the game
continues nothing
um uh the special is happening here you
can now play Knight to D1 i2f2 kick away
the Bishop from H3 if black continues
with the attack with something like H4
you can even play G for now the bishop
is trapped on H3 so this would be good
for white however in the game a white
overreached a little bit wide played
Pawn to F4 uh but white did not realize
that it was in fact black who's
attacking here there will be no attack
here from White so Pawn to H4 now comes
F characters on E5 Queen captures on F5
and just Bishop to F4 and while this is
a very nice Square for the bishop
attacks the queen guards the G3 Square
you've left this diagonal open so Bishop
the C5 with check King the H1 and now
there are many ways to win this position
for black but there is only one truly
impressive uh way so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the best move
for black while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh remembering
that the title of the video is uh well
sacrificing the queen three times and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is H captors and G3 this is
the quickest way to win and this is what
our good friend Bill Habiba he played
now the point is if white accepts the
Queen Bishop captures an F3 ninjas G2 is
checkmate with the bishop covering this
diagonal the G1 square is not available
to the white king so this is off limits
what can you play here after each
captors and G3 well he finds a way to
continue he plays Bishop to F3 of course
this now guards the G2 Square so G2 is
impossible but Bill Habib continues in
the absolute strongest fashion and that
is Queen to H5 offers his Queen a second
time again with the same idea the bishop
cannot leave control of the G2 square if
Bishop captures the G2 is just Checkmate
so is there a way to continue this game
well here Rook the E3 was played
defending the bishop but whatever you
play is insufficient here even if you
try to give up the queen it will not
help you like Bishop captures The Rook
captures and now look at this bishop to
G2 check even sacrificing the bishop and
now after King captures is just a queen
captures an H2 check King to F1 and
queen to F2 will be Checkmate but in the
actual game Rook the E3 was played
defending the bishop but uh Bishop uh
well uh though you you don't need to
defend the bishop you need to keep the
bishop somehow but whatever white plate
there was no saving this position now
comes the actual Queen sacrifice Queen
captures on F3 with the check and this
one you really can't decline you can you
can play King to G1 and then Queen will
just deliver Checkmate so Rook captures
on F3 was played and now the move that
was lurking uh uh you know of for the
duration of the entire attack that is
spawned to G2 this was played and it was
in this position on move 21 that Bel
Habib Mahi delivered over to this
spectacular Checkmate offering his Queen
three times before it actually happened
but only the third time was the queen
accepted so okay the he he titled the
email I sacrificed my queen three times
when in fact it was uh offered two times
and accepted the three times but you
know people always
um uh uh argue where whether it's a
queen sacrifice if you've merely offered
a queen and your opponent declines that
I believe it still is I mean uh just the
offer of the queen is is enough to uh
deem it a a sacrifice I would say uh but
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh you you see you don't have
to be 2700 to play a brilliant game and
uh sacrifice the queen not once not two
times but three times uh you can also do
it at any rating and here I mean it's uh
it's a game basically between uh two
1700 players uh where they played a very
nice Theory it was a very nice very nice
game and then white at some point just
overreached with this F4 idea with F3
the game still continues it's a fine
position for both but F4 is just asking
too much out of the position and black
punished it in the most beautiful way
possible uh so yeah uh that's it for
this game thank you thank you guys for
watching if you play a game like this be
sure to send it to me I will show it for
everyone to enjoy as that is why why we
are here to you know enjoy chess games
uh so you know if you if you have some
two to three games saved and you have a
really nice one do send it over I will
definitely go over it and uh and uh if
it's a nice one I will share it with
everyone because I go through all of the
games you guys send me it's not like I
don't don't do it but they are rarely as
fine as this one uh so yeah uh that's
the game I hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to thank uh subramanian Aaron
is the best fiance Marcus grebel Wesley
the greatest in James Chambers for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and I forgot
to mention that after the game his
opponent who just lost this game
messaged him and complimented him on on
the beautiful moves that he played which
if you play online uh you know that
that's usually not the case if you play
a beautiful game your opponent will just
you know send you a message saying
you're a cheater you're an engine user
you're you know say some nasty words but
no uh here even shapir complimented him
and uh well that's uh just uh a way to
really appreciate chess because you
don't just appreciate winning you
appreciate when your opponent plays a
brilliant game as well so yeah that's it
see you soon have an excellent rest of
your day